tail carrier all evil speech keep away
from Evil speech don't back bite unless
you're warning against somebody is
allowed to do
that on the chapter of the
tongue go back to these books you find
lot
in when he mentioned the Z set up show
you sity because this tongue can make
you enter the Hellfire the distance
between the East and the West this Tong
can make you enter the
Hellfire 70 autumns mean 70 years this
tongue is dangerous if you don't use it
in the of Allah recitation of Quran and
enjoying the good and forbidden the evil
so many people crying out for Islam busy
yourself in learning and and in teaching
them Islam and the sunah may Allah
reward the brothers who go out regularly
into and they have the the da tables may
Allah reward them rain or shine they're
dead and how many people become Muslim
we have to be part of we have to be part
of the goodness in our work places we
have to invite people to the de of
[Music]
Allah it's better for you than the red
sheep camel if they become Muslim better
for you than a Ferrari